exactamente
484 días después de comenzar la invasión
de Ucrania el régimen de Vladimir Putin
se enfrentó a un intento de golpe de
estado que ha dejado al descubierto las
grandes debilidades de un país que hace
aguas a finales de febrero de 2022
Vladimir Putin estuvo a punto de hacerse
con kiev ahora ha estado en riesgo su
control sobre Moscú y quizás sobre toda
Rusia la pregunta que ahora todos nos
estamos haciendo es exactamente qué
demonios ha pasado por qué ha pasado y
probablemente la pregunta más importante
de todas qué podemos esperar a partir de
ahora pues bien os lo vamos a contar
todo en este vídeo prestad mucha
atención porque habrá cosas que seguro
ya sepáis pero otras que os van a
sorprender arranquemos
[Música]
sábado 24 de junio de 2023 armadas
pertrechadas Y listas para el combate
las tropas de un señor de la guerra
atraviesan a toda velocidad el
territorio ruso para hacerse con Moscú
el kremlin Mientras tanto acorralado y
atónito intenta frenar el avance de esta
columna Armada poniendo barricadas
cortando carreteras y saboteando puentes
todo es inútil las tropas del Señor de
la Guerra avanzan sin descanso queridos
amigos amigas en esta ocasión no se
trata de ninguna película de Hollywood
ni ninguna novela de Tom clancy nada por
el estilo en esta ocasión esta historia
es completamente cierta todos hemos sido
testigos de ella en cierta manera los
días 23 y 24 de junio de 2023 lo
impensable se hizo realidad
jeffganisgotzin el líder del grupo de
mercenarios Wagner le echó a Vladimir
Putin el mayor pulso que se recuerda en
la historia de la Rusia moderna ahora
bien en este vídeo no os vamos a contar
ni quién es exactamente pregot sin ni
cómo funciona el grupo Wagner o como es
posible que llegara a tener 50.000
soldados y se hiciera con la única Gran
Victoria de Rusia en Ucrania desde el
mes de abril de 2022 bahamut no no lo
haremos porque de todo eso ya os hemos
hablado en varios vídeos que os dejamos
en la descripción por eso en esta
ocasión vamos a centrarnos en esta
singular historia más propia de una
superproducción de Hollywood que de los
noticiarios de actualidad y lo primero
de todo es saber qué pasó Y cómo se
llegó hasta aquí
[Música]
Pues veréis los altos mandos del
ejército Ruso y el líder del grupo
Wagner llevan meses tirándose los
trastos a la cabeza y no penséis que lo
hacen Precisamente en privado en petit
comité no ha hecho entrevistas vídeos y
publicaciones en redes sociales para
denunciar la incompetencia y la
corrupción de los gerifaltes militares
de Rusia particularmente del ministro de
defensa sergeygu y del jefe del Estado
Mayor el general Valery gerasimov
por su parte tras la captura de bakmuth
El Ministerio de defensa puso en marcha
un plan para reducir el creciente peso
del grupo Wagner para ello enrolaría en
el ejército a los reclutas de este grupo
y pondría toda su estructura bajo el
control del ministro saigu algo que por
supuesto era completamente inaceptable
para el mandamás de Wagner Al fin y al
cabo hubiera supuesto en la práctica su
disolución su respuesta incrementar sus
denuncias por corrupción en competencia
masiva contra los altos mandos militares
con todo el pulso definitivo se puso en
marcha el viernes 23 de junio cuando
brigotzin acusó al ejército ruso de
atacar los campamentos de su grupo de
mercenarios matando a un montón de
combatientes de Wagner culpó
específicamente al ministro de defensa
Ruso sergeygu y prometió tomar
represalias y vaya así lo hizo en un
vídeo de 30 minutazos el líder de los
Wagner se desahogó a gusto dijo de todo
reconoció que la Guerra de Ucrania no
estaba justificada dijo que las élites
del gobierno ruso eran una panda de
corruptos y dijo que todo se había
orquestado para llenar los bolsillos de
los jefecillos de turno
[Música]
Claro que eso sería solo el comienzo el
siguiente paso fue ocupar la ciudad de
rostov del Don una importante ciudad de
más de un millón de habitantes y un
centro militar absolutamente clave para
el esfuerzo de guerra de Rusia en
Ucrania desde luego esto supuso cruzar
una línea de no retorno
y amigos mientras los wagners se
preparaban Para ocupar rostov del Don el
sábado 24 de madrugada el fiscal general
de Rusia anunció que se estaba
investigando
precisamente una rebelión y aún más unas
horas después el propio Vladimir Putin
se dirigió a la nación y básicamente
acusó a su antiguo Aliado de ser un
traidor prometió castigar a los
responsables con toda la dureza posible
fijaos
Smith
y terraria
habían anunciado Ni más ni menos que
ponían rumbo a Moscú lo llamaron la
marcha por la justicia y ojo que no se
trataba de ninguna broma Aunque en la
operación de Wagner no se llegó a ver
ningún gran despliegue de tropas y
equipos el kremlin tuvo que poner en
marcha los planes que había de La Era
soviética para defender la capital de
locos
[Música]
en previsión de la llegada de las tropas
de prigocine se colocaron barricadas se
bloquearon carreteras se sabotearon
algunos puentes y se desplegó a todos
los efectivos disponibles conforme a los
planes
Moscú quedaría bajo la custodia de la
cuarta división de tanques de la guardia
cantemirovskaia y la segunda división
motora de la guardia se calcula que unos
6000 hombres en total junto a ellos
unidades de las fuerzas especiales de
sped la guardia nacional y la policía
[Música]
finalmente nada de esto fue necesario
como todos sabéis a última hora de la
tarde y cuando el grupo de mercenarios
se encontraba ya muy cerca de la capital
se anunció una especie de tregua los
wagners dieron marcha atrás después de
haber cruzado cientos de kilómetros sin
oposición alguna y después de haber
derribado seis helicópteros y un avión
del ejército ruso pese a ello Rusia ha
acordado retirar cualquier acusación por
rebelión veremos si lo cumple pero es lo
anunciado pero como os digo queridos
amigos todo esto es algo que estoy
seguro absolutamente seguro de que todos
Ya sabéis sin embargo hay unas cuantas
preguntas que tenemos que hacernos Por
qué pregotchin se lanzó a semejante
Aventura que ha significado realmente
esta incursión golpista Por qué se frenó
la tentativa de golpe de estado de los
Wagner cuando estaban tan cerca de Moscú
Y seguramente la pregunta más importante
de todas Qué puede suponer todo esto
para el futuro de Rusia Pues bien
veamoslo
crónica de un desmadre anunciado
os lo hemos contado en visualpolitik en
un montón de vídeos más allá de toda la
propaganda que existe Lo cierto es que
la Guerra de Ucrania está siendo un
desastre colosal para Rusia
prácticamente ningún ruso está ganando
nada y la mayoría están perdiendo en el
país la economía se está resintiendo y
las proyecciones futuras son muy pobres
ahora los rusos están mucho más aislados
y la libertad de expresión se ha
reducido aún más si cabe por su parte
los grandes oligarcas han perdido una
fortuna y muchísima libertad digamos que
su lujoso tren de vida viajando y siendo
agasajados por todo el mundo se ha visto
seriamente comprometido pero por
supuesto la peor parte Se ha producido
en Ucrania desde que dio comienzo la
guerra Las bajas han sido salvajes Rusia
ha perdido una gran parte de su fuerza
militar Y ahora para colmo están a la
defensiva el contraataque ucraniano
puede que esté siendo más lento de lo
esperado pero está castigando
durísimamente a las Ya de por sí
exhaustas tropas rusas y ojo esto no lo
decimos nosotros lo dice el propio
perigotzin un tipo que durante meses ha
sido la cara visible del esfuerzo
militar de Rusia fijaos
está Sacada
pero no se trata solo de pigotzin Lo
cierto es que los datos que se van
conociendo no invitan al optimismo para
Rusia por ejemplo los datos de las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas reconocidos
en buena medida por el propio pigotzin a
que Las bajas de Rusia están siendo no
solo muy superiores a las de Ucrania
sino dos veces más altas que las
sufridas Cuando comenzó la ofensiva de
gerson en el verano de 2022 y lo mismo
podemos decir de las pérdidas de equipo
y si ya sé lo que estaréis pensando pero
vamos a ver Alberto datos de Ucrania
estás de broma esos están más
maquillados que las hamburguesas que
salen en los anuncios de la tele Pues sí
es muy probable que sea así pero también
lo Es que de estar maquillados ahora
también lo estaban en el verano del 2022
y que los datos occidentales van en la
misma línea y que el propio picotching
también lo está reconociendo y por eso
lo que nos importa no es tanto el dato
en concreto sino la tendencia que está
siguiendo la guerra
os hablaremos de esto con todo lujo de
detalles en un próximo vídeo
activision lo que aquí nos importa ahora
es que esto no es algo nuevo
durante meses el líder del grupo Wagner
ha denunciado a los altos jerifaltes
rusos por no proporcionarles la munición
y el equipo necesarios y les ha culpado
de las grandes pérdidas sufridas y
sabéis que esto resulta algo fundamental
el fracaso militar en Ucrania está
obligando por un lado a buscar culpables
y por otro está creando grietas en el
sistema que muchos pueden querer
aprovechar para incrementar su poder que
es precisamente lo que parece haber
hecho perigo sin Durante los últimos
meses por un lado lavar su
responsabilidad y señalar a otros como
culpables antes de que esos otros le
señalaran a él por otro subir peldaños
en el escalafón de poder y por eso el
propio líder de los Wagner ha exigido
por activa y por pasiva la destitución
de los grandes gerifaltes del gobierno
Ruso y constantemente les ha llamado de
todo y como evidentemente soy gerasimo
nos han quedado de brazos cruzados pues
Hemos llegado hasta aquí pero un momento
porque esta historia nos deja unos
cuantos interrogantes Por qué el
ejército incluida la fuerza aérea no
actuó ni tampoco se movilizó claramente
para repeler el golpe es que acaso en el
kremlin no se fiaban de que alguna
división pudiera incumplir sus órdenes y
ponerse de lado de los sublevados si se
elevaba aún más la atención por qué el
propio Putin acusó por la mañana a los
Wagner de ser unos traidores y dijo que
recibirían su castigo para luego horas
más tarde dejarlos marchar de rositas es
que en el kremlin no tienen Claro que
puedan vencerlos fácilmente Por qué
recurrir a un intermediario como
lukashenko es que acaso tuvieron miedo
de que se pudiera llegar a perder Moscú
O al menos una parte de la capital con
el golpe político que eso hubiera
supuesto Por qué Putin y el resto de
altos cargos del gobierno estuvieron tan
desaparecidos realmente el presidente
llegó a abandonar Moscú por miedo a lo
que pudiera pasar ya no se fía de su
círculo más próximo cómo es posible que
tal y como se ha confirmado la
inteligencia americana supera desde hace
días las intenciones de Wagner y al
kremlin en cambio pareció pillarle todo
por sorpresa sin ningún preparativo
efectivo es que acaso la información ya
no fluye por qué pregotchin se lanzó
contra Moscú y cuando estaba tan cerca
se dio la vuelta Aparentemente sin
ningún éxito concreto es que acaso
esperaba el apoyo de alguna facción
crítica con el gobierno que finalmente
no se materializó fue este el caso del
comandante de las fuerzas aéreas El
general surovikin y del subjefe del Gro
el teniente general Álex que hicieron
sendas declaraciones algo extrañas
Llamando a los Wagner a desistir estaban
acaso detenidos o estaban siendo
forzados cuando hicieron estas
declaraciones puede ser que el líder de
Wagner haya palpado una creciente
distancia entre las filas militares y el
gobierno y de esta forma pensará que su
acción podría desencadenar un efecto
dominó pero que al final Esto no se
produjo no lo sabemos pero Esta es la
teoría a la que apuntan los servicios de
inteligencia occidentales podría
explicar por qué se dio la vuelta y
también por qué Putin no quiso movilizar
a las fuerzas armadas ni enfrentarse
directamente a los wagners en cualquier
caso ya veis que toda esta historia nos
deja muchas preguntas muchos
interrogantes para los cuales por ahora
no tenemos más que conjeturas pero
amigos amigas mejor o peor montado e
independientemente del riesgo que
supusiera realmente lo cierto es que el
golpe de mano de brigotching ha dejado
una cosa muy pero que muy clara
La Mafia es como la mafia sea cual sea
el acuerdo al que se llegó hoy se ha
derramado sangre y la ilusión de
invencibilidad de Putin se ha
desvanecido él y sus compinches probaron
el miedo real
Moscú estaba amenazado Gary casparo
amigos amigas el poder de Putin ya no es
el de antaño atentos
el jefe en entredicho
[Música]
durante la Guerra de Ucrania el grupo
Wagner y especialmente su líder han
cobrado cada vez más y más protagonismo
primero como líder de las principales
operaciones después como azote de la
cúpula militar Y últimamente también
como protector de los pobres soldados
rusos
[Música]
para ello no ha dudado en grabar vídeos
condenando la pérdida de soldados rusos
ha hecho regalos a sus vidas y a sus
madres y sobre todo ha dicho verdades
sobre la guerra que nadie más se atrevía
a decir en Rusia estas son cosas que en
Rusia venden y mucho lo que ha
multiplicado su popularidad solo hay que
ver cómo abandono entre aplausos y
vítores tras acordarse La tregua con el
gobierno
[Música]
Pero por qué Putin permitió durante
tanto tiempo que este tipo atacará sin
cuartel a su gobierno os preguntaréis
Pues bien una de las razones que se
barajaban es que con todas estas
denuncias ayudaba al propio presidente
ruso
es decir explico subo un amigo y Aliado
ponía en la Diana a personajes como soy
gu o gerassimo ellos eran Los Auténticos
culpables de lo mal que iban las cosas
no el presidente sin embargo con su
vídeo del viernes 23 de junio Todo
cambió porque una cosa es decir que
falta munición y otra muy distinta a
decir abiertamente que los argumentos
para justificar la invasión fueron una
patraña y por eso Putin salió en
televisión a decir que perygotching
básicamente era un traidor el problema
que de facto se ha tenido que retractar
Aparentemente ya no le va a perseguir Y
eso es un problema porque deja claro que
el mandamás de Rusia ya no tiene tanto
poder como antes
me veo obligado a admitir con amargura
que la federación de Rusia se ha
acercado un paso más a su muerte
definitiva e irrevocable victory
mantobich alexnys ex miembro de la URSS
y exdiputado de la duma estatal de la
federación rusa hoy el mundo vio que los
amos de Rusia no tienen control sobre
nada solo un completo caos bolo de
mirzalanski sí es verdad que
Aparentemente según el acuerdo alcanzado
pregotchin parece que dejará Rusia pero
significará esto que dejará su creciente
influencia renunciará a manejar los
hilos ya veis que hay serias dudas
también está por ver qué ocurrirá con la
cúpula militar si Putin hace cambios eso
podría interpretarse como parte del
acuerdo con bajen
pero sea como sea si algo está claro es
que todo esto ha supuesto un enorme
varapalo para Putin el presidente ruso
ha provocado un desastre en Ucrania está
perdiendo la guerra y ahora esto fijaos
en lo que decía en el mes de enero el
periodista ruso mijail sigar el
presidente Vladimir Putin de Rusia al
parecer finalmente se ha dado cuenta de
que la guerra en Ucrania creó un
peligroso competidor para su poder Jenny
prigocin micaelciega por supuesto lo del
motín fue ir mucho más allá Putin ya no
da el miedo de antaño Y eso eso es lo
peor que le puede pasar a un autócrata
en regímenes como este El poder del
presidente se basa esencialmente en su
capacidad para atemorizar infundir
respeto y castigar cualquier disidencia
pero en esta ocasión hemos visto como
una organización de 25.000 mercenarios
se apoderó del centro neurálgico de
operaciones para la Guerra de Ucrania y
avanzó hacia Moscú sin que pasara
absolutamente nada el
hecho de que esto haya sido moderado por
lucasenco me parece extremadamente
vergonzoso Putin necesita que alguien
más resuelva sus problemas sangrine
experto en política rusa director de
cepa y profesor del King's College de
Londres y no olvidéis que en marzo de
2024 se celebrarán elecciones que sí lo
sabemos en Rusia las elecciones están
más amañadas que el proceso de elección
del mundial de Qatar pero aún así
veremos si Putin consigue llegar y si
logra presentarse a la reelección
[Música]
Piénsalo bien la gran propuesta el gran
compromiso del presidente ruso siempre
ha sido rescatar a Rusia de la anarquía
y restablecer su grandeza pero ahora
todo se ha hecho añicos Rusia no es más
fuerte su ejército va de mal en peor no
hay prosperidad en el país los grandes
oligarcas están perdiendo Y para colmo
el caos es tan grande que un señor de la
guerra puede pasearse tranquilamente por
el país amenazando con ocupar la capital
sin que le pase absolutamente nada por
si fuera poco el acuerdo alcanzado con
los wagners parece conllevar la salida
de este grupo armado de una guerra que
todavía no ha terminado yo recuerdo que
hasta ahora este grupo ha sido clave
Wagner fue el único elemento exitoso de
la invasión rusa Durante un año y su
éxito fue muy limitado y se centró en
una pequeña ciudad y sus tácticas fueron
bárbaras incluso para el personal de
Wagner Pero al menos lograron algo el
ejército ruso no podía andris agoron ex
miembro de defensa de Ucrania la pinta
que nos deja todo esto es la de un país
en descomposición y ojo que hay
precedentes en 1991 El Líder soviético
mijail gorbachov logró sobrevivir a un
golpe de estado pese a ello sólo cuatro
meses después ya estaba fuera del
gobierno El golpe
mostró su enorme debilidad estaremos
ahora ante una situación muy parecida os
hablaremos de todo ello en un próximo
vídeo aquí en visualpolitik de momento
el turno es para ti qué opinas del golpe
de mano de los wagners Quién crees que
ha perdido más pregotzin o Putin crees
que el líder ruso conseguirá recuperarse
de todos estos varapalos como afectará
esto a la Guerra de Ucrania déjanos tus
impresiones en los comentarios y
hablamos debate y ahora si este vídeo te
ha resultado interesante No olvides
darle al botón de like y suscribirte a
visualpolitik si es que aún no lo has
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]